okay let's get right into audience
questions for the week there are some
important ones this week notable in that
they relate to what seems to be sort of
an understanding from the left that
things are changing and we'll see if you
agree that the questions this week seem
to have that theme first question hey
David I like Alexandria Casio quartz
house but I think she keeps saying
really dumb things in interviews she
seems totally unprepared what advice
would you give her yeah so earlier this
week I discussed that while I believe
AOC has a lot of the right ideas on some
things maybe she's a little less right
but for the most part she has a lot of
the right ideas I pointed out that she
is saying some dumb things and that if
you can't communicate ideas effectively
or be prepared to answer basic questions
about your ideas you actually do more
damage to the movement than maybe you
help it because it is it becomes a data
point that our opponents politically can
point to and say look Alexandria
Castillo Cortez has idea X and she gets
to talk about it in in corporate media
and here's how bad it went when she did
so even though the ideas are good if she
can't defend them then it is a liability
so my advice not that she's looking for
my advice and not that I'm the right
person to be giving her advice would be
basically twofold number one and I
assume she's gonna do this you've got to
get media training okay it was very
clear from the interviews she gave
during her campaign that her media
training was lacking or non-existent and
by that I don't mean experience doing
interviews I mean there are media
trainers who will explain to you how to
not get wrapped up in logic and semantic
games by the interviewer how to pivot
how to when you are asked to loaded or
unfair question coming prepared with the
five most likely ways that your point of
view will be challenged and exactly how
to respond in a way that doesn't open
you up to more criticism this is a skill
that you can learn not everybody is as
naturally
talented at it I would say there are
people who are just naturally better and
others who struggle more but it's a
skill that can be learned not everybody
can be a superstar but I think anybody
who is clearly of the level of
intelligence that Alexandria Castillo
Cortez has can be way better than she is
so she's she has to get media training
like yesterday and I'm guessing that as
part of her becoming a member of
Congress with the Congress ready to be
sworn in in January 2019 that's going to
happen and if she doesn't get that it
almost doesn't matter how good her ideas
are because she's going to get crushed
it's the same thing with Trump Trump's
ideas are terrible I mean truly terrible
ideas and he knows nothing about most of
the topics that that relate to those
ideas trade economics currency all of
the stuff but he was able to portray a
degree of confidence that people voted
for him thinking he knows about trade he
knows about economics his experience
running businesses many of which filed
for bankruptcy is going to translate
into being a good president so
perception is reality and the perception
that people are getting from these AOC
interviews is that not only is she
unprepared but that the ideas are bad
and that risks taking down the entire
movement the other thing is I might stop
tweeting okay and what I mean by that is
in the same way that Donald Trump has
gotten himself into way more trouble
than he would otherwise be in with
regard to Trump Russia it would be a
really good idea for aoc to stop
tweeting things like implied threats to
Donald Trump jr. to use Congress's
subpoena power for what might be
political vendetta's now I know the
defense is no she's just saying if
you've done stuff wrong we are going to
use subpoena power to find that out she
also maybe needs to be advised as to
what it doesn't doesn't make sense to
tweet because my prediction is she's not
going to be as Teflon as Donald Trump
has been with regard to tweets and even
though tweets have caused a lot of
problems for Trump they've also a lot of
stuff has that he's tweeted that has
been outrageous has not caused a problem
for him I think it's risky for her to to
employ the same thing better training
media training maybe ease up a little
bit on the
tweets and she hopefully will be able to
do just fine